hi nick how are you i'm very well
thank you how are you doing you look
fantastic
well that's very generous i'll pass that
right back
at you oh thank you the pandemic has
been good to you you look stunning and
the last time we saw each other was also
a party it was a long time ago yeah
uh megan and i came to a party at your
house
in the hollywood hills and it was a
the only time in my life i've been to an
actual toga party
i'm not kidding as nick attests i am
that guy
i threw a major like 500 person
animal house style toga party and you
were with your wife megan mullally
is a goddess she i
i love her as karen obviously on will
and grace she changed the course of all
of our lives and embodied a character
that became so famous and iconic
which is such a not easy feat for an
actor to do
absolutely and um imagine
what a lucky donkey you would feel like
if every morning you
wake up and she's laying there next to
you
it's pretty crazy and how did you woo
this goddess we met doing a play
21 years ago um and i invited her
on a date and i left her uh
i left her a message and it turned out
it was a bit of a dirty trick the
phone number that she had and this used
to be a thing when you had to like
for especially for women that might be
uh that might be harassed by
people um you would give a fake
number so on the cast list she put her
fax number and i so it turned out that i
had
left a message on her fax machine and
couple weeks later she saw the light
blinking on her fax machine
and listened to it and so it scored me
some points and it also scored me some
guilt points because then she felt bad
and
she had to actually go out to dinner
with me to make it up to me
and the rest is history and here we are
on the drew barrymore show
and that's not the only time that you
kind of
went for it didn't a post-it help you
land another job as well
uh yes i was auditioning for a part on
the office
and the part the creator of parks and
rec was a writer
on the office and i was auditioning for
him
and he really liked me and he wanted to
cast me in the part but i couldn't do it
but so he wrote my name on a post-it and
put it on his computer monitor
to remind himself three years later when
they said hey
greg daniels said i want we want to do a
show together which became
parks and recreation he said aha i have
this post-it
i want this guy nick offerman on the
show and it ended up working out
thankfully and for my rap gift he
found the post-it and he had it framed
and gave it to me
that we have a picture of it i went in
to read for
poltergeist and i didn't get the part
but i got to come back for e.t
and that's that you know timing is
everything sometimes it's a better thing
that something didn't work out and it's
great that you have
evidence of that and by the way even
your first gig in like 1996 was a little
unorthodox you're on a nickelodeon show
called kablam will you tell us about
that character of yours
yeah the i mean midriff shirts used to
be contractual with me that was my thing
back in the 90s my friend greg harrison
made this show called kablam
and he brought me to los angeles to play
the bad guy
and it was like a car it was like a
live-action cartoon
so it was cartoon acting even though we
were real people but the sets
looked like cartoons and it was really
fun
uh and and crazy and was it was an
incredible introduction to hollywood
i love that and speaking of animated um
you play a single dad
named beef on the animated series the
great north
i'm so excited about this what are we
gonna get into
well i'm the dad of this family the cast
is just bananas all-stars
aparna nancherla jolse sloan megan
mulally
jenny slate will forte paul rust
and on and on the guest cast is just
crazy and so
to get to like play with all these
people who just make me laugh
constantly in in a vessel
through which we're just delivering
medicine we're making people laugh
but it's also really good-hearted one of
my sons is gay
like there's there's there's all kinds
of like social issues being addressed
so we're subtly trying to help all of us
be more decent through a funny cartoon
it's it's like really wholesome
messaging
with farts and we need that
comedy is medicine it just is and
i live for it
you